اعتقد ان الرد الاسرائيلي
جرى الحديث طبعا عن رد محدود لكن حتى الان
لا شيء يؤكده ما اذا كانت القذائف التي
سقطت في القليله هي اسرائيليه ام لا لكن
الرد الاسرائيلي يمكن ان يكون واحدا من
ثلاثه اما الرد التقليدي باستهداف مراكز
القصف واما رد غير تقليدي كما حدث قبل سنه
من الان عندما كان هناك تهديد اسرائيلي
وقامت اسرائيل بخرق الاجواء فوق بيروت
لخافه السكان في لبنان وكان هذا بمثابه رد
مغاير لكل الردود التي كانت تحدث في
السابق وبطبيعه الحال احتمال الرد الثالث
وهو فتح معركه مع حزب الله وهذا احتمال
اعتقد دونه حسابات معقده في النهايه في كل
المواجهات السابقه راينا هناك فصل ما بين
الجبهه في لبنان والجبهه
الشماليه في المحكومه بقواعد ومحكومه
بظروف معينه وبالتالي
حساباتها تاخذ معنى اخر لان المعركه مع
لبنان معنى ذلك اننا ربما نكون على ابواب
معركه مفتوحه كلنا يمكن ان نعرف كيف بدات
لكن لا يمكن ان نعرف كيف يمكن ان تنتهي